- Willkommen zurück zu „Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation".
Mein Name ist John Watrous und ich bin der technische Direktor
für IBM Quantum Education.
Dies ist die dritte Lektion der Reihe. In den ersten beiden Lektionen haben wir über die Grundlagen
der Quanteninformation gesprochen.
Zuerst für einzelne Systeme in Isolation und dann für mehrere Systeme.
Wir haben auch Standardbasismessungen und unitäre Operationen
sowohl im Einzel- als auch im
Mehrsystemkontext besprochen.
In dieser Lektion stellen wir
das quantum circuit-Modell vor, das uns eine Standardmethode zur Beschreibung von Quantenberechnungen bietet,
und wir können quantum circuits auch verwenden, um Quantenprotokolle und andere Arten von Interaktionen zwischen mehreren Quantengeräten zu beschreiben.
Zusätzlich zu quantum circuits werden wir auch einige
wichtige mathematische Konzepte im Zusammenhang mit Quanteninformation besprechen,
und wir werden sie nutzen, um
einige grundlegende Einschränkungen der Quanteninformation zu beobachten und was wir mit quantum circuits tun können.
Das bereitet uns gut auf
die folgende Lektion vor, in der wir einige
sehr wichtige Beispiele sehen werden, und damit wird die
erste Einheit der Reihe abgeschlossen
zu den Grundlagen der Quanteninformation.
Hier ist eine Übersicht der Lektion. Wir beginnen mit dem quantum circuit-Modell und sehen uns an, wie es funktioniert.
Dann sprechen wir über den
überaus wichtigen Begriff des inneren Produkts sowie über Orthonormalität und Projektionen,
die mit inneren Produkten zusammenhängen. Diese Dinge haben wir
in den ersten beiden Lektionen nicht besprochen, weil wir sie wirklich nicht
gebraucht haben, aber jetzt schon.
Innere Produkte bieten uns
ein mathematisches Werkzeug, auf das wir einfach nicht verzichten können.
Wir kämen beim Verständnis von Quanteninformation und
-berechnung ohne innere Produkte einfach nicht weit.
Und im dritten Teil der Lektion werden wir uns einige
wichtige Einschränkungen der Quanteninformation ansehen.
Letztendlich wollen wir interessante
Dinge erkunden, die wir mit Quanteninformation tun können, aber um dies effektiv zu tun,
müssen wir uns einiger
Dinge bewusst sein, die wir nicht tun können.
Insbesondere werden wir
den Begriff der globalen Phase besprechen und warum globale Phasen irrelevant sind.
Wir werden eine Formulierung des
No-Cloning-Theorems kennenlernen, das uns sagt, dass Quantenzustände im Allgemeinen nicht kopiert werden können, und wir werden sehen, dass zwei Quantenzustände
nicht perfekt
voneinander unterschieden werden können, außer wenn sie orthogonal sind, was eine grundlegende
Einschränkung ist, die man kennen sollte.
Das erste Thema der Lektion
ist das quantum circuit-Modell, ein Berechnungsmodell,
das uns eine Methode bietet,
Quantenberechnungen zu beschreiben.
Das quantum circuit-Modell basiert
auf einem allgemeineren Begriff in der Informatik, nämlich dem eines circuit, und man kann viele
verschiedene Berechnungsmodelle
auf Basis dieses allgemeinen Begriffs definieren.
Die Grundidee ist, dass ein
circuit aus Leitungen besteht, die Informationen übertragen, und gates, die Operationen darstellen,
die auf die
von den Leitungen übertragenen Informationen angewendet werden.
Der Begriff circuit ist eigentlich
ein etwas merkwürdiger Name für diese Art von Modell,
denn das Wort circuit
bezieht sich normalerweise auf einen
kreisförmigen Pfad irgendeiner Art.
Aber wenn wir über circuits
als Berechnungsmodelle sprechen, reden wir normalerweise
von azyklischen circuits,
bei denen kreisförmige Pfade nicht erlaubt sind.
Um genauer zu sein: Für die
Zwecke dieser Reihe werden wir verlangen, dass
Informationen in jedem circuit immer von links nach rechts fließen.
Wenn du möchtest, kannst du
circuits also als Beschreibungen von Operationssequenzen betrachten, bei denen die Zeit von links nach rechts verläuft.
Hier ist ein Beispiel eines Booleschen circuit, bei dem die Leitungen binäre
Werte übertragen, entweder null oder eins,
und die gates
Boolesche Logikoperationen darstellen.
Die Leitungen werden durch Linien dargestellt, und hier haben wir zwei Eingabe-
bits, bezeichnet als X und Y,
und wenn wir wissen wollen,
was der circuit bei einer bestimmten Eingabe tut, propagieren wir die Werte auf
den Leitungen von links nach rechts,
abhängig von den Aktionen,
die die gates auf die Werte ausüben, die
von den Leitungen übertragen werden.
Zum Beispiel können wir
uns ansehen, was passiert, wenn wir die obere Eingabeleitung auf den Wert eins und die untere Eingabeleitung
auf den Wert null setzen.
Diese beiden Eingabeleitungen führen
zu diesen beiden Punkten hier, die Fan-out-Operationen darstellen, was bedeutet, dass der Wert kopiert wird,
sodass er
entlang mehrerer Leitungen weitergeleitet werden kann.
Wenn wir das also tun, nehmen diese
beiden Leitungen den Wert eins an, der gleich wie dieser eins ist, und diese beiden Leitungen nehmen den Wert null an,
der gleich wie dieser null ist.
Hier haben wir ein NOT-gate, das
durch das Symbol für logische Negation angezeigt wird, sodass der
ausgegebene Wert eine null ist,
die logische Negation von eins. Und ebenso ist der Wert,
der aus diesem gate kommt, eine eins, die die
logische Negation von null ist.
Diese beiden gates sind AND-gates,
dieses gate ist ein OR-gate, und wenn wir fortfahren
und die Werte propagieren
durch den circuit, wobei die
gates entsprechend ausgewertet werden, dann sehen wir, dass der endgültige Wert
auf diesem Draht hier eine Eins ist.
Der gesamte circuit beschreibt also
eine Folge von Operationen, die wie die Abbildung zeigt zusammengesetzt sind, und wir erhalten eine Funktion
von zwei Bits zu einem Bit
in diesem speziellen Fall. Aber im Allgemeinen könnte es beliebig viele
Ein- und Ausgangsbits geben.
Dieser spezielle circuit berechnet zufällig das exklusive ODER der beiden Eingangsbits, also ist die Ausgabe eine Eins
genau dann, wenn
eines der beiden Eingangsbits auf eine Eins gesetzt ist und das andere auf eine Null gesetzt ist, aber das ist eigentlich
nicht wichtig, es ist nur ein Beispiel.
Es ist eine grundlegende Tatsache über Boolesche circuits, dass jede Funktion von einer beliebigen Anzahl von Bits zu einer beliebigen Anzahl von Bits berechnet werden kann
durch einen Booleschen circuit, obwohl man manchmal einen
sehr großen circuit benötigt, um die Funktion zu berechnen,
an der du interessiert bist.
Es gibt andere Stile, die
zur Beschreibung von circuits verwendet werden.
Diese Abbildung zum Beispiel
stellt genau denselben circuit dar wie zuvor, in einem Stil, der vielleicht typischer ist
in der Elektrotechnik, wo es Konventionen für die Formen gibt, die verschiedene gates darstellen.
Wir werden diesen bestimmten
Stil nicht verwenden, aber wir werden
eigene Symbole für verschiedene Quanten-gates einführen, wie Hadamard gates,
Controlled NOT gates,
Toffoli gates und so weiter.
Nebenbei bemerkt können wir hier den Ursprung
des Begriffs circuit sehen.
Im Kontext der Elektrotechnik ist es sehr natürlich,
daran zu denken, dass Elektrizität durch einen circuit fließt.
Aber in dieser Serie sprechen wir nicht
davon, dass Elektrizität durch circuits fließt, wir sprechen davon, dass Informationen
durch circuits fließen.
Und für uns werden sie immer azyklisch sein, wobei die Informationen
von links nach rechts fließen.
Hier ist ein anderes Beispiel für
einen anderen Typ von circuit, einen sogenannten arithmetischen circuit.
Diesmal speichern die Drähte Zahlen und die gates stellen
arithmetische Operationen wie Addition und Multiplikation dar.
Hier kannst du ein Beispiel
für einen arithmetischen circuit sehen.
Es ist für diese Lektion nicht wichtig,
was er tut, es ist nur ein Beispiel, das
die Idee vermitteln soll, dass es verschiedene
Begriffe von circuits gibt.
Wir können auch über
circuits nachdenken, die Zufälligkeit beinhalten, zum Beispiel, wo die gates
probabilistische Operationen darstellen, und wenn du wolltest,
könntest du wahrscheinlich den ganzen Tag damit verbringen, neue Berechnungsmodelle auf Basis des circuit-Konzepts zu erfinden.
Im Quanten-circuit-Modell
stellen die Drähte Qubits dar, und die gates stellen sowohl unitäre Operationen als auch Messungen dar.
Hier ist ein sehr einfaches Beispiel
für einen Quanten-circuit.
Es gibt nur ein Qubit in diesem circuit, das durch
die horizontale Linie dargestellt wird, und die gates, die
durch Quadrate angezeigt werden,
stellen unitäre Operationen dar, die auf diesem Qubit ausgeführt werden.
Es gibt also keine Messungen
in diesem speziellen Beispiel.
Wenn wir dem
Qubit einen Namen wie X geben möchten, können wir das im Diagramm anzeigen, indem wir ein X genau
hier setzen, das ist optional.
Genau wie beim Booleschen circuit von vor einem Moment können wir diesen circuit
als eine Folge von Operationen betrachten, wobei die Zeit
von links nach rechts verläuft.
Wir beginnen also mit X,
wenden das erste gate an, das ein Hadamard gate ist,
gefolgt von einem S gate,
dann ein weiteres Hadamard
gate, und schließlich ein T gate.
Wir haben diese Operationen
gegen Ende von Lektion eins gesehen, und hier kannst du
ihre Matrixdarstellungen sehen.
Wenn wir also diese
vier Operationen der Reihe nach ausführen, was bedeutet zuerst H, dann
S, dann nochmal H, und dann T,
ergibt die kombinierte Operation
dieses Produkt hier, wobei zu beachten ist, dass die Reihenfolge
im Wesentlichen umgekehrt wird
wie wir in Lektion eins besprochen haben. Wenn wir die Matrixmultiplikation durchführen, erhalten wir diese Matrix hier,
und so wird die Wirkung des
circuits auf das Qubit X durch diese unitäre Matrix beschrieben.
Manchmal möchten wir in einem Quanten-circuit-Diagramm explizit angeben,
welchen Eingabewert wir einspeisen, und das können wir tun, wie du hier siehst.
In diesem Fall geben wir
Ket 0 in den circuit ein.
Das ist ziemlich üblich. Wir nehmen oft Ket 0 als
den initialisierten Zustand eines Qubits, aber das ist nicht notwendig.
Wir könnten auch in Betracht ziehen,
den circuit auf einen anderen Zustand anzuwenden.
Wenn wir möchten, können wir auch
den Ausgabezustand angeben, den wir so erhalten.
Hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel, bei dem
wir diesmal zwei Qubits namens X und Y haben, wie du
im Diagramm sehen kannst.
Hier haben wir ein Hadamard gate, das auf das Qubit Y angewendet wird, gefolgt von dem gate, das durch
dieses Symbol hier angezeigt wird,
das ein Controlled NOT gate ist. Wir haben die
Controlled NOT Operation in der vorherigen Lektion besprochen,
und hier in diesem Diagramm können wir
sehen, dass das Steuer-Qubit Y ist, was durch
den kleinen ausgefüllten Kreis angezeigt wird,
und das Ziel-Qubit ist X, was durch den großen Kreis mit einem Plus-Zeichen darin angezeigt wird.
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie das
Symbol für das exklusive ODER, also macht es Sinn.
Du kannst dir vorstellen, dass der klassische Zustand, der in Y gespeichert ist, auf das Qubit X XOR-verknüpft wird.
Und der Klarheit halber ist hier das Diagramm, das
die Wirkung dieses gate auf Standard-Basiszustände zeigt,
wobei wir davon ausgehen, dass A
und B binäre Werte sind.
Für andere Zustände wird die Wirkung
wie immer durch Linearität bestimmt.
Bevor wir weitermachen, ist es hilfreich,
eine Konvention explizit festzulegen, der wir folgen werden, was die Reihenfolge von qubits betrifft
in quantum circuit-Diagrammen wie diesem hier.
Die Konvention besagt, dass
die Reihenfolge von unten nach oben in einem quantum circuit-Diagramm der Reihenfolge von links nach rechts entspricht
wie in einem Tupel oder einem Tensorprodukt.
Das ist eine Konvention, der wir
in dieser Reihe folgen werden, und es ist auch die Konvention,
die in Qiskit verwendet wird.
Für diesen speziellen circuit hier denken wir also daran,
dass er auf ein Paar von qubits X, Y wirkt,
X kommt zuerst, weil es unten ist, und Y kommt zuletzt oder als zweites in diesem Fall, weil es oben ist.
Zur besseren Vorstellung kannst du dir,
falls es hilft, vorstellen, diesen
circuit im Uhrzeigersinn zu drehen, sodass die Eingaben oben sind
und die Ausgaben unten sind, und die Reihenfolge der
qubits wird stimmen.
Manchmal bringt diese Reihenfolge Leute durcheinander, also achte darauf,
diese Konvention im Hinterkopf zu behalten.
Wenn wir also über die Wirkung nachdenken, die dieser circuit beschreibt, haben wir zunächst ein
Hadamard gate, das auf Y angewendet wird,
und dann ein Controlled NOT
gate auf den zwei qubits, wobei Y die Steuerung
und X das Ziel ist.
Wenn wir eine unitäre Matrix aufschreiben wollen, die die kombinierte
Wirkung dieser zwei gates beschreibt, können wir das tun.
Zuerst betrachten wir das Hadamard gate auf Y.
Wir wenden das Hadamard gate auf Y an und tun nichts mit X, was gleichwertig ist mit
der Durchführung einer Identitätsoperation auf X.
Die Wirkung des Hadamard gate auf beide qubits zusammen wird also
durch das Tensorprodukt der Identitätsmatrix und
der Matrix gegeben, die
die Hadamard-Operation auf Y darstellt.
Das sieht so aus, wobei wir unsere
Konvention im Hinterkopf behalten, dass X zuerst und Y als zweites kommt, also ist es
die Identität tensoriert mit H.
Dann wenden wir die
Controlled NOT-Operation an, die diese Matrixdarstellung
hat, und das stimmt wieder mit unserer Konvention überein.
Das zweite qubit Y ist die Steuerung und das erste qubit X ist das Ziel.
Scheue dich nicht, das Video anzuhalten und zu überprüfen, ob das Sinn macht – ich werde dich nicht mehr daran erinnern.
Du kannst diese Videos pausieren, Abschnitte
so oft zurückschauen, wie du möchtest, die Wiedergabegeschwindigkeit anpassen, wenn du willst, und sie auf jede
Art nutzen, die für dich am besten funktioniert.
Wenn wir die
beiden Operationen zusammensetzen, wird die kombinierte Wirkung
durch dieses Produkt hier beschrieben,
und diese zwei Matrizen werden
in dieser Reihenfolge multipliziert, weil das Hadamard zuerst und das Controlled NOT
als zweites durchgeführt wird,
und das stimmt einmal mehr
mit dem überein, was wir in Lektion eins besprochen haben, wo sich die Reihenfolge
im Wesentlichen umkehrt.
Wenn wir die Matrixmultiplikation durchführen, erhalten wir diese Matrix hier.
Und wir können aus dieser Matrix ablesen, was der circuit mit
Standard-Basiszuständen macht.
Wenn wir den circuit mit dem Eingabezustand 0, 0 ausführen, also Ket 0 für das erste qubit, Ket 0 für das zweite qubit,
ist das Ergebnis der Phi+ Bell-Zustand, den wir aus der
ersten Spalte der Matrix ablesen können.
Wenn wir 0, 1 eingeben, erhalten wir den Phi- Zustand, eins null ergibt den Psi+ Zustand,
und 1, 1 ergibt nicht Psi-, sondern -1 mal Psi-.
Das Minuszeichen ist
hier nicht wirklich bedeutsam. Wenn du das nicht haben möchtest, könntest du eine Swap-
Operation auf den zwei qubits durchführen,
um es loszuwerden, und du würdest nicht durcheinanderbringen, was mit den ersten drei Standard-Basiszuständen passiert ist.
Aber das ist für den Zweck dieses Beispiels
wirklich nicht wichtig.
Zusammenfassend hat der circuit diese Wirkung hier auf Standard-Basiszustände.
Wenn du darüber nachdenkst,
was ein bestimmter circuit tut, musst du nicht durch
die Umwandlung in Matrizen und deren Multiplikation gehen,
du kannst auch die
Wirkung nachverfolgen, die der circuit auf bestimmte Zustände hat, und in vielen Fällen wird das
die bevorzugte Option sein.
In diesem Beispiel können wir zum Beispiel sehen, was der circuit
mit dem Zustand 0, 0 macht, indem wir die Wirkung der gates untersuchen.
Der Ausgangszustand, den
wir hier Pi null genannt haben, nur um einen Namen
zu vermeiden, der mit den Bell-Zuständen verwechselt werden könnte, ist 0, 0.
Wir wenden das Hadamard gate an und der Zustand, den wir erhalten, ist 0+, den wir so ausschreiben können,
und dann bringt die Controlled NOT-Operation diesen Zustand in den Phi+ Zustand, was wir sehen können, indem wir
über die Wirkung nachdenken, die das Controlled NOT auf
Standard-Basiszustände hat,
und du kannst dasselbe
für die anderen drei Standard-Basiszustände oder jeden
anderen Zustand tun.
Wir können auch klassische Bits in quantum circuit-Diagramme einbeziehen.
Sie werden durch
doppelte Linien angezeigt, wie du in diesem Diagramm siehst.
Das heißt, A und B sind klassische Bits und X und Y sind qubits.
Wir haben dieselben zwei unitären gates wie im vorherigen Beispiel, und diese Symbole hier stellen Standard-Basismessungen dar
Konkret werden nach den zwei
unitären Operationen eine Standardbasismessung
an Y durchgeführt
und das Ergebnis wird
in das klassische Bit B überschrieben, und ebenso wird X gemessen und das Ergebnis in das Bit A geschrieben.
Hier siehst du, dass die Qubits X und Y nach ihrer Messung weiter bestehen.
Es ist jedoch ziemlich üblich,
dass wir uns nicht allzu sehr um Qubits
nach ihrer Messung kümmern.
Manchmal interessiert uns nur
das Messergebnis. In einem solchen Fall können wir die Kurzschreibweise
verwenden, die du hier siehst
bei der Messungen Qubits als Eingabe und klassische Bits als Ausgabe haben.
Das Verständnis hier ist, dass
die Qubits nach ihrer Messung einfach verworfen oder ignoriert werden und das klassische Messergebnis
weitergeführt wird.
Im weiteren Verlauf der Serie werden wir viele
Beispiele von quantum circuits sehen, und diese werden typischerweise
viel komplizierter sein als die sehr einfachen
Beispiele, die wir gerade gesehen haben.
Wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, werden verschiedene Symbole für
verschiedene gates verwendet.
Einzelne qubit gates werden normalerweise
einfach als Quadrate mit einem Buchstaben dargestellt, der angibt,
welche Operation es ist.
Manchmal sind diese verschiedenen
gates farblich kodiert, um unterschiedliche Dinge zu bedeuten, aber
das ignorieren wir für jetzt.
Wir haben das
Controlled NOT gate bereits gesehen.
Swap gates werden
so dargestellt, wie du es hier siehst, und Toffoli gates und Fredkin gates
werden so dargestellt, wie du es hier siehst.
Denke daran, dass ein Toffoli gate ein kontrolliertes Controlled NOT gate ist und ein Fredkin gate
ein kontrolliertes Swap gate ist.
Diese Symbole sind also
konsistent mit der Idee, dass ein Kontroll-qubit
durch einen ausgefüllten Kreis mit einer Linie dargestellt wird, die es
mit dem gate verbindet, das es kontrolliert.
Im Allgemeinen müssen Kontroll-qubits
nicht oben sein, und diese gates müssen nicht
auf benachbarte Qubits wirken, was bedeutet, dass diese gates
überbrückt werden können
über andere Qubits hinweg, auf die sie nicht wirken, und das werden wir
in zukünftigen Lektionen sehen.
Eine weitere Sache, die wir beim Verwenden des quantum circuit Modells häufig tun, ist es, beliebige unitäre Operationen
auf einer beliebigen Anzahl von Qubits
so zu betrachten, als wären sie einzelne gates, wie du es hier siehst.
Einfach indem wir ein Rechteck mit einer Bezeichnung zeichnen, die
der jeweiligen unitären Operation entspricht.
In diesem Fall ist es eine
unitäre Operation U.
Natürlich wissen wir nicht,
was U aus diesem Diagramm ist; wir müssen davon ausgehen, dass
U irgendwie definiert ist oder dass wir eine beliebige
unitäre Operation U betrachten, vielleicht. Es könnte zum Beispiel sein, dass
wir U einfach als eine Unterroutine betrachten wollen
im Interesse der Klarheit.
Wir verwenden auch diese Notation,
die du hier siehst, für eine kontrollierte U-Operation,
bei der das Kontroll-qubit durch einen ausgefüllten Kreis
angezeigt wird, genau wie zuvor.
Das war also eine kurze Einführung
in das quantum circuit Modell. Und wie ich bereits sagte, werden wir viele weitere
Beispiele von quantum circuits sehen
wenn wir in der Serie fortfahren.
Im nächsten Teil der Lektion werden wir uns
innere Produkte, Orthonormalität und Projektionen ansehen, die sehr wichtige Konzepte sind
in der Quanteninformation und -berechnung.
Wir beginnen mit inneren Produkten.
Denke daran, dass wenn wir
die Dirac-Notation verwenden, ein Ket ein Spaltenvektor
und ein Bra ein Zeilenvektor ist,
und insbesondere ist der
Bra-Vektor, der einem gegebenen Spaltenvektor entspricht, das konjugiert Transponierte
dieses Spaltenvektors.
Für diesen Vektor hier erhalten wir den entsprechenden Bra-Vektor, indem wir den Vektor transponieren,
als wäre er eine Matrix,
was bedeutet, ihn auf die Seite zu legen und dann das komplex Konjugierte jedes Eintrags zu nehmen.
Angenommen, wir haben zwei Kets mit der gleichen Anzahl von Einträgen wie hier.
Wenn wir dieses Bracket hier bilden, was einfach bedeutet, dass
wir das Produkt aus dem Bra und dem Ket nehmen,
als wären sie Matrizen,
dann erhalten wir diesen Ausdruck,
den du hier siehst, der ein Skalar ist, oder mit
anderen Worten eine komplexe Zahl.
Dieser Wert wird als inneres Produkt
dieser zwei Vektoren bezeichnet.
Du kannst innere Produkte auch in Form von Vektoren der
Form betrachten, die du hier siehst, wo die Vektoren als Linearkombinationen
ausgedrückt werden
von Standardbasisvektoren.
Das innere Produkt dieser Vektoren ist auf die gleiche Weise definiert wie
zuvor, Bra Psi mal Ket Phi, was wir
als ein Produkt wie dieses ausdrücken können.
Und wenn wir berechnen und vereinfachen, erhalten wir diesen Ausdruck hier für das innere Produkt, der analog zu dem ist, was wir zuvor hatten,
außer dass wir diesmal
die Summe über Elemente in unserer klassischen Zustandsmenge nehmen, das ist in diesem besonderen Fall sigma.
Hier ist ein Beispiel, das dir ein geometrisches Bild davon geben soll,
wie innere Produkte funktionieren.
Hier habe ich einen Kreis
in einem zweidimensionalen Raum gezeichnet, der einem qubit entspricht, und solange wir unsere Aufmerksamkeit beschränken
auf Vektoren mit reellen Zahlen als Einträge, können wir sie als Punkte in dieser Ebene zeichnen.
Nehmen wir Phi als
diesen Vektor hier.
Es ist ein Einheitsvektor, was wir sehen können, indem wir
die euklidische Norm berechnen, und das ist es, was dieser Kreis darstellt,
es sind alle Einheitsvektoren
mit reellen Einträgen.
Nennen wir außerdem Psi
diesen Vektor hier, der ebenfalls ein Einheitsvektor ist.
Es ist tatsächlich der Minus-Zustand, aber hier nennen wir ihn einfach Psi.
Wenn wir das innere Produkt
dieser beiden Vektoren berechnen, erhalten wir eins minus die Quadratwurzel aus drei durch zwei mal Wurzel zwei,
was ungefähr -1/4 ergibt.
Der Wert dieses inneren Produkts ist gleich dem Kosinus des Winkels
zwischen den beiden Vektoren, wie du hier in der Abbildung sehen kannst.
Das gilt allgemein
für Einheitsvektoren. Wenn wir zwei Einheitsvektoren haben und beide reelle Einträge haben,
dann ist das innere Produkt zwischen ihnen gleich dem Kosinus des
Winkels zwischen ihnen.
Insbesondere, wenn das innere Produkt
gleich null ist, wie in diesem Beispiel, wo wir Psi zu
diesem Zustand hier geändert haben,
dann müssen die beiden Vektoren
in einem 90-Grad-Winkel zueinander stehen.
Das lässt sich alles verallgemeinern auf
Vektoren in beliebiger Dimension, übrigens, solange die
Einträge reelle Zahlen sind, es gilt nicht nur für zweidimensionale Vektoren.
Wenn wir komplexe Einträge haben, funktioniert das Bild nicht mehr wirklich,
aber dennoch ist das innere Produkt genauso
nützlich, wie wir sehen werden.
Das innere Produkt hat einige
sehr wichtige Eigenschaften, und wir werden uns einen Moment Zeit nehmen, um einige dieser Eigenschaften jetzt zu betrachten.
Erste ist eine Verbindung
zwischen dem inneren Produkt und der euklidischen Norm.
Wenn wir das innere Produkt
eines beliebigen Vektors mit sich selbst nehmen, erhalten wir die euklidische Norm im Quadrat.
Wir können also alternativ sagen, dass die euklidische Norm eines Vektors gleich der Quadratwurzel
des inneren Produkts ist
dieses Vektors mit sich selbst. Das ist kein Zufall, das
ist eine fundamentale Verbindung, und hier können wir sehen, dass wenn wir nicht
die komplexen Konjugierten in der Definition des inneren Produkts hätten, dann wäre diese Formel
nicht mehr wahr, und wir hätten keine so nützliche Begrifflichkeit
mit dieser fundamentalen Verbindung
zur euklidischen Norm.
Als nächstes ist das innere Produkt
konjugiert-symmetrisch, was bedeutet, dass wenn wir die
Reihenfolge der beiden Argumente vertauschen, der Wert, den wir für das
innere Produkt erhalten, konjugiert wird.
Das wird durch
diese Gleichung hier ausgedrückt und es ist recht einfach zu sehen, warum das für diese beiden Ausdrücke passiert
für das innere Produkt der beiden Vektoren in den beiden möglichen Reihenfolgen.
Das innere Produkt ist linear
im zweiten Argument. Insbesondere, wenn wir einen Vektor Phi als diese Linearkombination zweier Vektoren definieren,
Phi eins und Phi zwei, dann ist das innere Produkt
eines beliebigen Vektors Psi mit Phi dieselbe Linearkombination
der beiden inneren Produkte,
und das folgt ganz
direkt daraus, dass die Matrixmultiplikation linear ist.
Und wir haben auch, dass das innere Produkt
konjugiert-linear im ersten Argument ist, was du hier ausgedrückt sehen kannst.
Wenn Psi diese Linearkombination
von Vektoren ist, und wir das innere Produkt
von Psi und Phi nehmen,
dann wird Bra Psi zu diesem Vektor, den wir hier sehen, wo wir das komplexe
Konjugat von beta eins und beta zwei nehmen,
und so ist dies das Ergebnis, und das ist das, was mit
konjugierter Linearität gemeint ist.
Und die letzte Eigenschaft des inneren Produkts, die ich erwähnen möchte, ist
die unglaublich nützliche Cauchy-Schwarz-Ungleichung.
Für beliebige zwei Vektoren, Psi und Phi, kann der Absolutwert des inneren Produkts niemals größer sein als das
Produkt der euklidischen Normen
der beiden Vektoren. Und außerdem ist die einzige Möglichkeit, dass die beiden
Seiten der Ungleichung gleich sein können, wenn die beiden
Vektoren linear abhängig sind,
was bedeutet, dass einer von ihnen gleich einem Skalar mal dem anderen ist.
Das ist tatsächlich eine der
am häufigsten verwendeten Ungleichungen in der gesamten Mathematik, und
wir verwenden sie immer wieder, wenn wir über
Quanteninformation sprechen,
daher ist es sehr gut, sie zu kennen.
Als nächstes werden wir über die
Begriffe der Orthogonalität und Orthonormalität sprechen, die mit
inneren Produkten zusammenhängen
und insbesondere damit,
dass innere Produkte von Vektoren gleich null sind.
Genauer gesagt, wenn wir
zwei Vektoren haben, Psi und Phi, sagen wir, dass sie orthogonal sind,
wenn ihr inneres Produkt
gleich null ist. Und die Art, wie wir uns
orthogonale Vektoren intuitiv vorstellen können, ist, dass sie
rechtwinklig zueinander stehen,
oder alternativ, dass sie
senkrecht aufeinander stehen.
Manchmal verwenden Menschen den Begriff orthogonal, um Dinge zu beschreiben, die
nichts miteinander zu tun haben, etwa wenn man sagt, dass ein Thema
orthogonal zu einem anderen ist,
aber das ist offensichtlich recht informell und nicht wirklich bedeutsam
im mathematischen Sinne, aber die Verbindung ist klar, wenn du dir orthogonale
Vektoren vorstellst, die
nicht in entgegengesetzte Richtungen, sondern in völlig verschiedene Richtungen zeigen, wie zum Beispiel Norden gegenüber Westen.
Wenn wir eine Menge von Vektoren haben, sagen wir, dass die Menge eine orthogonale Menge ist, wenn je zwei verschiedene Vektoren,
die aus dieser Menge gewählt werden,
notwendigerweise orthogonal zueinander sind, was wir
so ausdrücken können, wie du es hier siehst,
Eine orthonormale Menge ist
einfach eine orthogonale Menge von Einheitsvektoren.
Vektoren in orthogonalen
Mengen müssen nicht unbedingt Einheitsvektoren sein, und tatsächlich könnte man
sogar den Nullvektor haben
ein Element einer orthogonalen Menge zu sein, aber in einer orthonormalen Menge muss jeder Vektor ein Einheitsvektor sein,
zusätzlich zur
Anforderung, dass die Menge eine orthogonale Menge ist.
Angesichts dessen, was wir über die Beziehung zwischen dem inneren Produkt
und der euklidischen Norm wissen, können wir diese
Bedingung recht prägnant ausdrücken,
wie du es hier siehst.
Und schließlich ist eine orthonormale Basis einfach eine orthonormale
Menge, die eine Basis für den jeweiligen Vektorraum bildet,
über den wir sprechen.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel eine beliebige
klassische Zustandsmenge Sigma nehmen und uns die Menge aller
Standardbasisvektoren vorstellen,
sehen wir, dass dies eine orthonormale Menge ist und tatsächlich eine orthonormale Basis für den Raum aller Vektoren, deren Einträge dieser
klassischen Zustandsmenge Sigma entsprechen.
Das sind alles Einheitsvektoren und
sie sind paarweise orthogonal, also ist es eine orthonormale Menge.
und weil es auch eine Basis ist, haben wir, dass es eine orthonormale Basis ist.
Orthonormale Mengen sind
übrigens immer linear unabhängig, also wann immer du
eine orthonormale Menge hast, wird sie immer eine orthonormale
Basis für einen Unterraum sein,
aber in diesem Fall haben wir eine Basis für den gesamten Raum, mit dem wir arbeiten.
Ein weiteres Beispiel ist die Menge,
die Ket+ und Ket- enthält.
Diese beiden Vektoren sind orthogonal, ihr inneres Produkt ist gleich null.
und sie sind beide Einheitsvektoren und sie spannen den
zweidimensionalen Raum der Vektoren auf, der einem einzelnen Qubit entspricht, also bilden sie eine orthonormale
Basis für diesen Raum.
Ein weiteres Beispiel ist die Bell-Basis, die eine orthonormale Basis für den Raum aller
vierdimensionalen Vektoren ist, die zwei Qubits entsprechen.
Die Menge, die Ket 0
und Ket+ enthält, ist hingegen keine orthogonale Menge, weil das innere Produkt zwischen
diesen Vektoren ungleich null ist.
Sie sind beide Einheitsvektoren und dies ist eine Basis für den Vektorraum, der einem Qubit entspricht, aber wir haben keine Orthogonalität.
Hier ist eine praktische Tatsache über orthonormale Mengen, die wir von Zeit zu Zeit nutzen werden.
Angenommen, wir haben eine
orthonormale Menge von Vektoren, genauer gesagt, nehmen wir an,
dass wir M Vektoren in dieser Menge haben, Psi eins bis Psi M,
wobei wir davon ausgehen, dass diese Vektoren aus einem N-dimensionalen
Vektorraum stammen, oder mit anderen Worten, jeder der
Vektoren hat N Einträge.
Wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, sind orthonormale Mengen immer
linear unabhängig, also kann es nicht sein, dass M größer als N ist,
aber es könnte sein, dass M kleiner als N ist, und das ist der Fall, der
uns interessiert.
Und was die Tatsache besagt, ist,
dass wenn M kleiner als N ist, es immer möglich ist,
zusätzliche Vektoren hinzuzufügen,
zu der Menge, mit der wir begonnen haben, um eine
orthonormale Basis für unseren Raum zu erhalten.
Genauer gesagt, müssen
notwendigerweise Vektoren Psi M+1 bis Psi N existieren, sodass die gesamte Sammlung
eine orthonormale Basis bildet.
Du kannst dich also sozusagen nie in eine Ecke manövrieren, indem du irgendwie eine
orthonormale Menge von Vektoren wählst, die nicht erweitert werden kann, um
eine orthonormale Basis zu bilden.
Manchmal kannst du einfach
die Menge, mit der du beginnst, anschauen und herausfinden, wie man sie erweitert, um eine orthonormale Basis zu bilden, aber eine Alternative, die immer funktioniert,
ist die Verwendung eines Verfahrens, das als Gram-Schmidt-
Orthonormalisierungsverfahren bekannt ist, um diese Vektoren zu konstruieren.
Ich werde dieses
Verfahren in dieser Lektion oder in dieser Serie nicht erklären, weil die Einzelheiten
für uns nicht wirklich wichtig sind, aber natürlich kannst du
es nachschlagen, wenn du neugierig bist.
Es ist etwas, das
von einem Computer durchgeführt werden kann, falls das relevant ist, also
ist keine Kreativität erforderlich, es ist nur ein mechanisches Verfahren.
Einer der Gründe, warum das
eine so praktische Tatsache ist, betrifft eine enge Verbindung, die zwischen orthonormalen
Basen und unitären Matrizen besteht.
Insbesondere sind für jede quadratische Matrix U die drei Bedingungen, die du hier siehst, immer äquivalent,
was bedeutet, dass sie entweder
alle wahr oder alle falsch sind.
Die erste Bedingung besagt,
dass U eine unitäre Matrix ist, was bedeutet, dass sowohl U Dagger mal U als auch U mal U Dagger beide
gleich der Einheitsmatrix sind.
Die zweite Bedingung
besagt, dass die Zeilen von U eine orthonormale Basis bilden,
und die dritte Bedingung besagt, dass die Spalten von U
eine orthonormale Basis bilden.
Es ist tatsächlich nicht allzu schwer
zu sehen, warum diese Äquivalenz wahr ist.
Der Einfachheit halber schauen wir uns eine
drei mal drei Matrix U an, wie du sie hier siehst, wobei die Einträge beliebige
komplexe Zahlen sein können.
Hier auf der linken Seite habe ich U konjugiert transponiert
der Einfachheit halber geschrieben.
Wenn wir drei Vektoren
aus den Spalten von U bilden, die hier Psi
eins, Psi zwei und Psi drei heißen, dann wenn wir das
Produkt von U Dagger und U nehmen,
kannst du überprüfen, dass jeder
Eintrag des Produkts durch ein inneres Produkt von Vektoren gegeben ist, wie wir es hier in diesem Muster sehen.
Und wenn du jetzt über die Bedingung nachdenkst, dass U unitär ist, was äquivalent dazu ist, dass diese Matrix gleich der Einheitsmatrix ist,
siehst du, dass es äquivalent
dazu ist, dass die drei Vektoren eine orthonormale Menge bilden.
Die Diagonaleinträge müssen alle
gleich eins sein, also sind das notwendigerweise Einheitsvektoren, und die Nebendiagonaleinträge müssen null sein,
also ist es eine orthogonale Menge von Vektoren.
Also ist U unitär zu sein äquivalent dazu, dass die Spalten eine orthonormale Menge bilden,
und das muss eine Basis sein, weil die Anzahl der Vektoren in der Menge, die in diesem Fall drei ist, mit der Dimension des Raums übereinstimmt,
mit dem wir arbeiten. Du kannst ein ähnliches Argument für die Zeilen statt der Spalten folgen, um zu schlussfolgern, dass U unitär zu sein äquivalent ist
zu den Zeilen, die eine Orthonormalbasis bilden.
Das funktioniert nicht ganz so schön, weil wir eine Anpassung vornehmen müssen, damit die komplexen Konjugierten
auf die richtige Weise funktionieren, aber die Idee ist dieselbe.
Ein alternativer Ansatz, der ziemlich unkompliziert ist, besteht darin zu beweisen, dass eine Matrix genau dann unitär ist, wenn ihre Transponierte unitär ist.
Und hier meine ich wirklich Transponierte und nicht konjugierte Transponierte.
Es ist ziemlich trivial aus der
Definition unitärer Matrizen, dass die konjugierte Transponierte
jeder unitären Matrix unitär ist,
aber es gilt auch, dass die Transponierte jeder unitären Matrix unitär ist.
Jedenfalls haben wir die
Äquivalenz zwischen diesen drei Bedingungen für jede quadratische Matrix U, und wir können diese Äquivalenz kombinieren
mit der Tatsache über
die Erweiterung orthonormaler Mengen zu orthonormalen Basen, um unitäre Matrizen zu konstruieren,
die interessante Dinge tun
oder verschiedene Anforderungen erfüllen, denen wir begegnen können.
Konkret gilt: Immer wenn wir
eine orthonormale Menge von M Vektoren haben, gibt es immer eine unitäre Matrix U,
deren erste M Spalten die Vektoren aus dieser orthonormalen Menge sind.
Die verbleibenden Spalten
können immer so aufgefüllt werden, dass wir eine unitäre Matrix erhalten, indem wir sie so wählen, dass die Spalten
eine Orthonormalbasis bilden. Das wird eine ziemlich
praktische Tatsache sein, die wir zur Verfügung haben.
Und ein weiteres Thema für
diesen Abschnitt der Lektion ist der Begriff der Projektion.
Eine quadratische Matrix Pi
heißt Projektion oder Projektionsmatrix, wenn die beiden hier aufgeführten Eigenschaften
beide wahr sind.
Das ist übrigens ein großes Pi – es ist eine ziemlich typische Wahl für einen Buchstaben, der zur Bezeichnung einer Projektion verwendet wird.
Wir geben solchen typischen Objekten wie Matrizen oft solche Namen, nur damit sie leichter zu erkennen sind und die Dinge klar bleiben,
aber du kannst jeden beliebigen Namen verwenden. Jedenfalls ist die erste Bedingung, dass Pi gleich seiner eigenen konjugierten Transponierten ist.
Im Allgemeinen, wenn wir eine Matrix haben, die gleich ihrer eigenen
konjugierten Transponierten ist, sagen wir, dass sie eine hermitesche Matrix ist.
Die erste Bedingung kann also alternativ so formuliert werden: Pi ist hermitesch.
Die zweite Bedingung ist,
dass wenn wir Pi quadrieren, also Pi
mit sich selbst multiplizieren, wir wieder Pi erhalten.
Das Quadrieren von Pi ändert also nichts an Pi.
Die Idee einer Projektion
ist intuitiv gesprochen ähnlich
wie das Projizieren eines Bildes auf einen Bildschirm oder das Fällen
eines Lotes auf eine Gerade,
zum Beispiel. Wenn du einen
Vektor mit einer Projektion multiplizierst, bewirkst du in gewissem Sinne,
einen Teil davon unverändert zu lassen
und den Rest auf null zu setzen.
Wenn du also eine
Projektion ein zweites Mal anwendest, bewirkt sie nichts, weil
du den Teil, den die Projektion auf null setzt, bereits auf null gesetzt hast.
Ein Beispiel für eine Projektion
ist diese Matrix hier für eine beliebige Wahl eines Einheitsvektors Psi.
Wir können überprüfen, dass sie die
erforderlichen Bedingungen eine nach der anderen erfüllt.
Für die erste berechnen wir
die konjugierte Transponierte, und das ist die konjugierte
Transponierte eines Produkts.
Wir können also diese Formel hier für die konjugierte Transponierte
eines Produkts zur Hilfe nehmen.
Was du erhältst, ist das Produkt
der konjugierten Transponierten, aber die Reihenfolge wird umgekehrt.
Das liegt am
Transpositionsteil.
Wenn wir also diese Formel anwenden, erhalten wir diese Gleichheit hier und können dann vereinfachen, um
die ursprüngliche Matrix zurückzubekommen.
Beachte übrigens, dass wir die Tatsache nicht verwendet haben,
dass Psi ein Einheitsvektor ist.
Diese Matrix ist also tatsächlich
hermitesch für jeden Vektor Psi, nicht nur für Einheitsvektoren.
Und für die zweite quadrieren wir Pi und erhalten
diesen Ausdruck hier, und das ist gleich der
ursprünglichen Matrix diesmal,
weil Psi ein Einheitsvektor ist, sodass dieses Skalarprodukt
hier gleich eins ist, und das ist der Punkt, wo die Annahme,
dass Psi ein Einheitsvektor ist,
ins Spiel kommt.
Wir können dieses Beispiel verallgemeinern und mit einer orthonormalen Menge beginnen.
Und wenn wir diese Matrix hier bilden, bei der wir die Projektionen der einzelnen Vektoren aufsummieren, erhalten wir eine Projektion.
Hier auf dem Bildschirm kannst du Berechnungen sehen, die das zeigen, und ich überlasse es dir,
sie zu untersuchen, wenn du möchtest.
Und ähnlich wie beim ersten Beispiel ist es die zweite Bedingung, bei der die Orthonormalität
der Menge verwendet wird.
Was diese Projektion tut, wenn
du sie mit einem Vektor multiplizierst, ist, diesen
Vektor auf den Unterraum zu projizieren, der von dieser Vektormenge aufgespannt wird,
was abstrakt gesprochen
wie das Fällen eines Lotes auf diesen Unterraum ist, und sobald
du in diesem Unterraum bist, bewirkt die Projektion nichts mehr.
Matrizen wie diese sind also
Beispiele für Projektionen, und tatsächlich haben wir jetzt
alle Möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft.
Jede Projektionsmatrix hat diese Form für eine bestimmte Wahl einer orthonormalen Menge.
Die Nullmatrix ist eine Projektion, also müssen wir
sicherstellen, dass wir diese einschließen, wenn wir jede Projektion erfassen wollen.
Um das klarzustellen: Wir lassen die
Möglichkeit zu, dass M gleich null ist, und das ergibt eine leere Summe,
die wir als Nullmatrix interpretieren können.
Jetzt, da wir den
Begriff der Projektion zur Verfügung haben, können wir eine allgemeinere
Klasse von Quantenmessungen definieren, die als projektive Messungen bekannt sind.
Das ist nicht der allgemeinste
Begriff einer Messung, aber er ist deutlich allgemeiner als Standardbasismessungen
und es wird sehr
hilfreich sein, ihn in unsere Beschreibung
der Quanteninformation aufzunehmen.
Eine projektive Messung wird durch eine beliebige Menge von Projektionen definiert,
die die Bedingung erfüllt, die du hier siehst, nämlich dass die Projektionen
zur Identitätsmatrix summieren.
Hier kann M eine beliebige
positive ganze Zahl sein, solange das alles Projektionen sind und diese Bedingung gilt,
definiert die Kollektion eine
projektive Messung.
Die durch eine solche Kollektion beschriebene
Messung funktioniert wie folgt, wenn du
einen beliebigen Quantenzustand Psi misst.
Zuerst erhältst du ein Ergebnis
zwischen eins und M, wobei M die Anzahl der Projektionen ist.
Für jedes mögliche Ergebnis K ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dieses Ergebnis zu erhalten, die euklidische Norm
im Quadrat des Vektors, den du erhältst,
wenn du S mit Pi
K, der K-ten Projektion, multiplizierst.
Wir können diese
Größe auch so schreiben, wie du es hier siehst.
Diese Gleichheit ergibt sich aus der Beziehung zwischen der euklidischen
Norm und dem inneren Produkt zusammen mit der Tatsache,
dass Pi K eine Projektion ist.
Aus der zweiten Form sehen wir, zusammen mit der Bedingung, die wir für diese Projektionen haben, sofort durch Linearität, dass unsere Wahrscheinlichkeiten
immer zu eins summieren,
wobei zu beachten ist, dass Psi
ein Einheitsvektor sein muss.
Und zweitens: Unter der Annahme, dass
wir das Ergebnis K erhalten, kollabiert der Zustand des Systems
zu dem Quantenzustand, den wir erhalten, indem wir den durch die Projektion erhaltenen Vektor normieren.
Wir werden uns gleich einige
Beispiele ansehen, aber bevor wir das tun, möchte ich erwähnen, dass wir die möglichen Ergebnisse eigentlich nicht
von eins bis M nummerieren müssen. Wir können beliebige Namen oder Symbole für die Ergebnisse wählen.
Insbesondere, wenn wir eine Kollektion von Projektionen haben, die mit Symbolen
aus einer Menge Gamma beschriftet sind,
und sie die
gleiche Bedingung wie zuvor erfüllen, nämlich dass sie
zur Identitätsmatrix summieren, dann haben wir eine projektive Messung,
die genauso funktioniert
wie zuvor.
Der einzige Unterschied hier ist, dass wir zulassen,
dass die Messergebnisse Elemente dieser Menge Gamma sind, anstatt der ganzen Zahlen von eins bis M.
Für unser erstes Beispiel einer
projektiven Messung wollen wir beobachten, dass
Standardbasismessungen projektive Messungen sind.
In diesem Fall ist die Menge der
Messergebnisse dieselbe wie die Menge der klassischen Zustände des jeweiligen gemessenen Systems.
Und die Menge der Projektionen,
die die Messung beschreibt, ist diese Kollektion hier, vorausgesetzt, dass sigma die
klassische Zustandsmenge ist
unseres Systems. Das sind alles Projektionen,
und wenn wir sie summieren, erhalten wir die Identitätsmatrix, also ist es eine gültige projektive Messung.
Um zu sehen, wie das im
Detail funktioniert, nehmen wir an, dass wir
einen beliebigen Zustand haben, der in der Form geschrieben ist,
die du hier siehst.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die
Messung das Ergebnis A liefert, ist gemäß der Beschreibung
von eben dieser Wert hier,
der gleich dem
Betragsquadrat des entsprechenden
Eintrags des Vektors Psi ist, was wir erwarten.
Bedingt auf das Ergebnis A wird der Zustand des Systems zu diesem hier, wiederum gemäß der
Beschreibung von eben.
Wenn wir vereinfachen, erhalten wir
nicht ganz den Zustand, den wir erwarten, nämlich Ket A.
Stattdessen erhalten wir Ket A
multipliziert mit einem Skalar, und konkret ist das ein Skalar mit
Betrag gleich eins,
also eine komplexe Zahl
auf dem Einheitskreis.
Das nennt sich globale Phase, und wir werden globale Phasen in Kürze besprechen, aber kurz gesagt ist dieser
Zustand äquivalent zu Ket A.
Diese globale Phase hat
eigentlich überhaupt keine Bedeutung, und wir werden sehen, warum,
wenn wir zur Diskussion der globalen Phasen kommen.
Also (unklar) dieses Problem der globalen Phasen, über das wir gleich sprechen werden, sehen wir, dass Standardbasismessungen
tatsächlich projektive Messungen sind. Für ein weiteres Beispiel, das wirklich eine Erweiterung
des vorherigen Beispiels ist,
wenn wir eine Standardbasismessung
an einem System X durchführen und nichts an einem System Y tun, genau wie wir
in der vorherigen Lektion besprochen haben,
ist das vollständig äquivalent
zum Messen des Systems X, Y.
Mit dieser projektiven
Messung hier.
Wir haben diese Projektionen entsprechend den klassischen Zuständen von X, und wir tensorieren mit der Identität auf Y,
was die Tatsache widerspiegelt, dass
wir nichts mit Y machen.
Die Beschreibung, wie
projektive Messungen im Allgemeinen funktionieren, sagt uns,
was in diesem Beispiel passiert, und ich überlasse es dir,
zu überprüfen, dass dies tatsächlich
vollständig äquivalent zu dem ist, was wir in der vorherigen Lektion besprochen haben.
Das ist alles sehr schön, denn diese projektive
Messbeschreibung ist in gewisser Weise übersichtlicher, und wir sehen, dass sie in dieses
allgemeinere Bild passt.
Hier ist noch ein Beispiel für
eine projektive Messung.
Dieses hier ist eine Messung von zwei Qubits.
Bei dieser Messung
haben wir zwei Projektionen und damit zwei mögliche
Ergebnisse, nämlich null und eins.
Die Projektionen sind
in Bezug auf die Bell-Zustände definiert, wie du hier siehst.
Die erste Projektion erfolgt
auf den Raum, der von den drei symmetrischen Bell-Zuständen aufgespannt wird, und die zweite Projektion erfolgt
auf den eindimensionalen Raum
der vom Psi- Zustand aufgespannt wird, welcher der antisymmetrische ist, oder mit anderen Worten der,
der mit einem
Minuszeichen multipliziert wird, wenn wir
eine Swap-Operation auf den zwei Qubits durchführen.
Wir werden später in der Serie sehen, warum das eine interessante Messung ist.
Für jetzt ist es nur ein Beispiel,
das mit etwas zusammenhängt, was wir bereits gesehen haben,
nämlich der Bell-Basis.
Ein letzter Hinweis zu projektiven Messungen: Immer wenn du eine
projektive Messung hast, kannst du diese Messung stets implementieren
mithilfe unitärer Operationen und
Standardbasismessungen.
Für dieses konkrete Beispiel einer
Messung können wir zum Beispiel ein quantum circuit bauen, das die Messung implementiert,
wie du es hier siehst.
Wir stellen uns vor, dass die oberen
zwei Qubits die Qubits sind, die wir mit
dieser projektiven Messung messen, und was wir tun können, ist
ein neues Qubit einzuführen,
das zunächst auf den Nullzustand initialisiert ist. Wir führen ein Hadamard gate
gefolgt von einem Fredkin-Gate, gefolgt von einem weiteren Hadamard gate durch,
und wenn wir dieses untere Qubit mit einer Standardbasismessung messen, wird der Effekt genau derselbe sein, als hätten wir die oberen zwei Qubits gemessen
mit der projektiven
Messung aus diesem Beispiel.
Wir erhalten genau dieselben Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die zwei Ergebnisse und der Effekt, den die Messung auf die oberen zwei Qubits hat,
wird ebenfalls derselbe sein.
Das ist keineswegs offensichtlich. Eine Analyse ist erforderlich, um das zu sehen, und diese Analyse wird hier nicht gezeigt.
Wie ich bereits angedeutet habe, werden wir uns
diese konkrete Messung in einer späteren Lektion genauer ansehen, und für jetzt
ist sie nur als Beispiel gedacht.
Der wichtige Punkt, den du mitnehmen solltest, ist, dass so etwas
immer möglich ist für jede projektive Messung, sodass wir durch
die Einführung projektiver Messungen keine wirklich zusätzlichen Möglichkeiten
gewinnen, aber es ist ein sehr nützliches Konzept und wir werden oft von
projektiven Messungen sprechen,
wenn wir in der Serie fortfahren. Der letzte Teil dieser Lektion behandelt einige wichtige Einschränkungen
der Quanteninformation
und was wir mit quantum circuits tun können.
Die erste Einschränkung, die vielleicht weniger eine Einschränkung als vielmehr eine Entartung ist, betrifft das Problem der globalen Phasen,
das ich vor kurzer Zeit erwähnt habe. Hier ist die Definition dessen, was wir meinen, wenn wir von einer globalen Phase sprechen.
Wenn wir zwei Quantenzustandsvektoren haben, Psi und Phi, sodass einer von ihnen
gleich dem anderen multipliziert mit einer komplexen Zahl alpha ist,
dann sagen wir, dass sich die Zustände
um eine globale Phase unterscheiden, oder alternativ, dass sie bis auf eine globale Phase äquivalent sind.
Beachte, dass, da Quantenzustandsvektoren die euklidische Norm gleich eins haben, die einzige Möglichkeit, dass diese
Gleichung wahr sein kann,
darin besteht, dass der Absolutwert
dieser komplexen Zahl gleich eins ist, also muss alpha
auf dem Einheitskreis liegen.
Stellen wir uns vor, dass wir
zwei Quantenzustände wie diesen haben, die sich um eine globale Phase unterscheiden, und nehmen wir an, dass wir den Zustand Phi messen
mit einer Standardbasismessung.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, ein Ergebnis A zu erhalten, wird durch diesen Ausdruck hier gegeben, und wenn wir
alpha mal Psi für Phi einsetzen,
was wir tun können, weil wir
annehmen, dass sie gleich sind, erhalten wir diese Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Und wenn wir vereinfachen, indem wir die Tatsache nutzen, dass alpha auf dem
komplexen Einheitskreis liegt, erhalten wir diese Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Denke daran, dass dies die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, dass die Messung von Phi das Ergebnis A liefert, aber jetzt sehen wir, dass
dies genau dieselbe Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, dass die Messung von
Psi das Ergebnis A liefert,
also gibt es absolut
überhaupt keinen Unterschied in den Wahrscheinlichkeiten verschiedener Ergebnisse für die zwei Zustände.
Ein ähnliches Argument sagt uns allgemeiner, dass für jede projektive Messung die Wahrscheinlichkeiten wieder identisch sind.
Durch Messen können wir also
den Unterschied zwischen zwei Zuständen, die sich um eine globale Phase unterscheiden, nicht erkennen, nicht einmal in einem statistischen Sinne.
Wenn wir schließlich eine beliebige unitäre
Operation auf den Zustand Phi anwenden, dann erhalten wir wieder durch Einsetzen genau
dieselbe komplexe Zahl alpha,
multipliziert mit dem, was wir erhalten, indem wir dieselbe unitäre
Operation auf den Zustand Psi anwenden.
Die zwei Zustände werden sich also immer noch
um eine globale Phase unterscheiden.
Das Fazit ist, dass die zwei Zustände vollständig ununterscheidbar sind, also gibt es wirklich keinen
Unterschied zwischen ihnen
in Bezug auf das, was wir
möglicherweise über sie erfahren können, indem wir unitäre
Operationen und Messungen durchführen, und aus diesem Grund
betrachten wir diese zwei
Zustände als äquivalent, oder wenn du möchtest, dass dies nur zwei möglicherweise verschiedene
Vektordarstellungen
desselben Quantenzustands sind.
Wie ich am
Anfang der Diskussion gesagt habe, ist es im Grunde Entartung
in der Art und Weise, wie Quantenzustände durch Quantenzustandsvektoren beschrieben werden.
In jedem Fall bedeutet das, dass wir
globale Phasen einfach ignorieren können, genau wie wir es effektiv getan haben, als wir Standardbasismessungen
als projektive Messungen beschrieben haben.
Übrigens tritt diese Entartung nur in der vereinfachten Beschreibung
der Quanteninformation auf.
Wenn wir Quantenzustände
mithilfe von Dichtematrizen beschreiben, wie wir es in der
dritten Einheit der Serie tun werden, werden wir eine eindeutige
Matrixdarstellung haben
für jeden Quantenzustand. Das Problem der globalen Phasen
tritt in der allgemeinen Beschreibung
der Quanteninformation einfach nicht auf.
Es ist ein weiterer ansprechender Aspekt
der allgemeinen Beschreibung der Quanteninformation,
auf die ich immer wieder anspielen, aber ungeachtet dessen werden globale
Phasen uns nicht stören
weil wir einfach die Freiheit
nutzen können, sie zu ignorieren.
Hier ist ein sehr kurzes Beispiel,
nur um sicherzustellen, dass der Begriff der globalen Phase klar ist.
Wenn wir einen Minus-Zustand und negativ eins mal einen Minus-Zustand haben, dann unterscheiden sich diese beiden Zustände
durch eine globale Phase, und insbesondere gilt
alpha gleich negativ eins.
Wenn wir andererseits einen Plus-Zustand und einen Minus-Zustand haben, dann haben wir keine zwei Zustände,
die sich durch eine globale Phase unterscheiden.
Das sind orthogonale Vektoren, also sind sie linear unabhängig.
Zu sagen, dass sich zwei Quantenzustandsvektoren um eine globale Phase unterscheiden,
ist gleichbedeutend damit zu sagen, dass die Vektoren linear abhängig sind,
also unterscheiden sich diese Vektoren
sicherlich nicht durch eine globale Phase.
Es stimmt, dass der einzige Unterschied darin besteht, dass dieses Plus-Zeichen
zu diesem Minus-Zeichen wird, aber das nennen wir einen
relativen Phasenunterschied.
Das unterscheidet sich von einer globalen Phase, weil wir nicht
den gesamten Vektor mit einer komplexen Zahl multiplizieren.
Und das stimmt mit der Tatsache überein, dass wir den Unterschied
zwischen diesen Zuständen erkennen können – insbesondere, wenn wir
eine Hadamard-Operation anwenden
und dann messen, sehen wir eine Null, wenn der
Zustand ein Plus-Zustand war, und eine Eins, wenn der Zustand ein Minus-Zustand war.
Die nächste Einschränkung der Quanteninformation, die wir in dieser Lektion sehen werden,
ist das No-Cloning-Theorem.
Hier ist eine Formulierung
des No-Cloning-Theorems, und diese besondere
Formulierung des Theorems ist ziemlich konkret und spezifisch,
was es einfacher macht, darüber zu sprechen. Es gibt andere allgemeinere Arten, das No-Cloning-Theorem zu formulieren,
aber wir konzentrieren uns vorerst auf diese.
Wir nehmen an, dass wir zwei Systeme X und Y haben, die dieselbe klassische Zustandsmenge besitzen.
die aus den
ganzen Zahlen von null bis D-1 besteht, wobei D mindestens zwei ist.
Es ist nicht wirklich wichtig, welche Namen die klassischen Zustände haben, aber durch die Wahl dieser Namen wird es einfacher, die Dinge übersichtlich zu halten.
Am wichtigsten ist
hier, dass es mindestens zwei verschiedene klassische
Zustände gibt – mit anderen Worten, wir machen uns keine Sorgen um den
trivialen und uninteressanten Fall,
wo wir nur einen klassischen Zustand haben.
Was das Theorem besagt, ist, dass es keine unitäre Operation U gibt, die wir auf X, Y anwenden können, sodass wenn wir
Y auf den Nullzustand initialisieren,
wir beliebige Quantenzustände von X
effektiv kopieren oder klonen.
Wenn wir uns diesen
Ausdruck hier für sich betrachten, sagt er, dass für alle Wahlen eines Quantenzustandsvektors Psi von X,
das Anwenden von U auf Psi tensor
mit dem Nullzustand uns Psi tensor Psi ergibt, oder mit anderen Worten zwei
unabhängige Kopien von Psi,
das ist also das, was es bedeuten würde, wenn wir Quantenzustände
klonen könnten, und was das Theorem besagt, ist, dass dies nicht möglich ist.
Du kannst das dir
in Bezug auf circuits vorstellen, und was das Theorem besagt, ist,
dass du nie in der Lage sein wirst, ein gate oder ein circuit
zu finden, das so funktioniert, wie du es hier siehst.
Wo eine Kopie des Zustands Psi zusammen mit einer Sammlung
von initialisierten qubits hereinkommt und zwei Kopien von Psi erzeugt werden.
Das kannst du für bestimmte
Wahlen des Zustands Psi tun, aber du kannst nie ein
circuit finden, das für jeden Quantenzustand Psi so funktioniert,
und das ist es, was das Theorem besagt.
Es ist ziemlich einfach, dieses Theorem zu beweisen –
tatsächlich läuft es im Wesentlichen darauf hinaus, dass die Transformation, nach der wir
suchen, nicht linear ist,
aber unitäre Operationen sind
linear, also kann es einfach nicht funktionieren.
Hier ist ein etwas detaillierteres Argument.
Angenommen, wir haben eine unitäre Operation U, die die Standardbasiszustände
Ket 0 und Ket eins klont.
Wir wissen, dass die klassischen
Zustände null und eins zu unserer klassischen Zustandsmenge gehören müssen, weil D mindestens zwei ist.
Aber das bedeutet durch Linearität,
dass wenn X in einem Plus-Zustand ist, den wir so schreiben können,
das Ergebnis diese Linearkombination dieser beiden Zustände hier ist.
Das ist jedoch nicht das richtige Verhalten. Die Anforderung an U ist, dass
U einen Plus-Zustand klont,
was bedeutet, dass wir
diese Gleichung hier erfüllt haben müssen.
Diese beiden Zustände sind nicht
gleich, also funktioniert es nicht, und das ist alles, was dazu zu sagen ist.
Nur noch ein paar zusätzliche Anmerkungen
zum No-Cloning-Theorem.
Erstens ist diese Formulierung des
No-Cloning-Theorems in gewissem Sinne absolut.
Es besagt einfach, dass eine unitäre Operation U, die genau so
funktioniert, nicht existiert.
Du könntest also fragen, ob
es eine unitäre Operation U gibt, die
das näherungsweise tut, in Bezug auf eine Möglichkeit zu beschreiben,
was eine Näherung der Aussage bedeutet. Es gibt verschiedene
Begriffe von Näherungen, an denen man interessiert sein könnte,
und wir werden in der dritten Einheit der Reihe einige
davon kennenlernen, aber für diese verschiedenen
Näherungsbegriffe
gibt es quantitative Aussagen
des No-Cloning-Theorems, die starke Grenzen dafür setzen, wie gut du näherungsweise klonen kannst.
Eine zweite Anmerkung ist, dass das Kopieren oder Klonen von Standardbasiszuständen
durchaus möglich ist.
Zum Beispiel kopiert ein Controlled-NOT gate die Standardbasiszustände eines qubit.
Das widerspricht nicht
dem No-Cloning-Theorem. Der Punkt ist, dass das Klonen im Sinne des No-Cloning-Theorems erfordert,
dass dies nicht nur
für Standard-Basiszustände,
sondern für alle Zustände.
Ein Controlled NOT gate
klont zum Beispiel keinen Plus-Zustand.
Und schließlich ist es erwähnenswert, dass es auch ein No-Cloning-Theorem für
probabilistische Zustände gibt.
Darüber spricht nur niemand
und es interessiert auch niemanden.
Wenn jemand zufällig
ein Bit wählt – zum Beispiel auf irgendeine willkürliche Art,
den beiden Werten Wahrscheinlichkeiten zuzuweisen –
und dir dann dieses Bit gibt,
gibt es natürlich keine Möglichkeit für dich, zwei unabhängige Stichproben
dieses zufälligen Bits zu erhalten.
Du weißt einfach nicht,
wie die Wahrscheinlichkeiten sind.
Du kannst das Bit kopieren, genau wie ein Controlled NOT
Standard-Basiszustände kopiert – aber das ist nicht dasselbe wie das Klonen des probabilistischen Zustands.
Du hast einfach nicht genug
Informationen dafür. Welches zufällige Bit du auch immer bekommen hast, es sagt dir nicht, wie die
Wahrscheinlichkeiten waren.
Es ist nur ein Bit.
Die Unmöglichkeit, einen
probabilistischen Zustand zu klonen, folgt aus genau derselben Überlegung wie im Quantenbereich.
Klonen ist ein nichtlinearer Prozess, während probabilistische Operationen, genau wie unitäre Operationen, linear sind.
Jedenfalls ist es nicht überraschend,
dass wir einen probabilistischen Zustand nicht klonen können –
und irgendwie ist es nicht so interessant wie die Tatsache, dass wir keinen
Quantenzustand klonen können,
aber der Punkt ist einfach festzustellen, dass dies kein einzigartiges
Quantenphänomen ist.
Die letzte Einschränkung
von Quanteninformation, die wir in dieser Lektion besprechen werden, ist, dass es nicht möglich ist,
zwei Quantenzustände perfekt zu unterscheiden,
die nicht orthogonal sind.
Anders ausgedrückt:
Wenn zwei Quantenzustände perfekt unterschieden werden können, müssen sie orthogonal sein.
Was wir meinen, wenn wir von
einer perfekten Diskriminierung zweier Quantenzustände, Psi und Phi, sprechen, ist, dass es eine
Möglichkeit gibt, sie zu unterscheiden,
ohne jede Fehlerchance.
Im Sinne des Quanten-circuit-Modells können wir dies ausdrücken, wie du
es hier auf dem Bildschirm siehst.
Wir haben eine unitäre Operation U, die als Quanten-circuit implementiert werden könnte,
oder wir können U einfach abstrakt betrachten,
als unitäre Operation,
und als Eingabe nimmt U entweder den Zustand Psi oder den Zustand Phi
zusammen mit einer Reihe initialisierter Qubits, die du dir als Arbeitsbereich-Qubits vorstellen kannst, die diesen
Diskriminierungsprozess irgendwie unterstützen.
Nachdem U angewendet wurde, wird das oberste Qubit bezüglich einer Standard-Basismessung gemessen – und hier kommt der Teil der perfekten
Diskriminierung.
Wenn der Eingangszustand Psi war, muss die Messung
das Ergebnis null ergeben, 100 % der Zeit, und wenn
der Eingangszustand Phi war,
dann muss die Messung
das Ergebnis eins ergeben, ebenfalls mit 100 % Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Es ist nicht wichtig, wie der
Zustand dieser anderen Qubits nach der Anwendung von U ist.
Alles, was zählt, ist dieses eine Bit, das wir aus der Messung erhalten, denn das ist das Bit, das uns sagt, mit welchem der beiden Zustände wir begonnen haben.
Für manche Kombinationen von Zuständen, Psi und Phi, wird es möglich sein, eine perfekte Diskriminierung wie
diese durchzuführen – für andere nicht.
Und was wir beobachten werden, ist, dass,
wenn es möglich ist, müssen Psi und Phi
orthogonale Zustände sein.
Das bedeutet, wenn Phi und
Psi nicht orthogonal sind, kannst du sie nicht perfekt diskriminieren.
Schauen wir uns also an, warum eine perfekte Diskriminierung Orthogonalität impliziert.
Wir beginnen damit, zwei Gleichungen aufzuschreiben, die ausdrücken, was diese
beiden Diagramme ausdrücken.
Wenn wir an den Quantenzustand denken, den wir nach der Anwendung von U auf eine
Reihe initialisierter Qubits zusammen mit dem Zustand Psi erhalten,
sehen wir, dass er
diese Form haben muss, wo Pi null ein Quantenzustandsvektor ist, der den Zustand
all dieser Qubits repräsentiert,
außer dem obersten. Wir haben keine Information
über diesen Quantenzustand, Pi null – er kann alles sein,
aber wir wissen, dass der gesamte
Zustand so aussehen muss, weil das die einzige
Möglichkeit ist, dass die Messung garantiert das
Ergebnis null ergibt, 100 % der Zeit.
Und wir haben eine analoge
Gleichung für den zweiten.
Diesmal muss das oberste Qubit
im Eins-Zustand sein, und ähnlich wie Pi null kann der
Zustand Pi eins alles sein.
Und zusätzlich dazu, dass wir
keine Information über Pi eins haben, wissen wir auch nichts
über die Beziehung zwischen Pi null und Pi eins.
Soweit wir wissen, sind das einfach zwei
beliebige Quantenzustände.
Was wir als nächstes tun können,
ist, beide Seiten dieser Gleichungen
mit U dagger zu multiplizieren, also dem konjugiert Transponierten von U.
Wenn wir das tun, erhalten wir die beiden Gleichungen,
die du hier siehst.
Wir nutzen die Tatsache, dass U dagger mal U die Einheitsmatrix ist.
Deshalb sehen wir U oder U dagger auf der linken Seite keiner der Gleichungen.
Und jetzt können wir das innere Produkt zwischen Psi und Phi betrachten.
Es ist dasselbe wie das innere
Produkt von Psi und Phi, multipliziert mit dem inneren
Produkt des L-Null-Zustands mit sich selbst,
denn das innere Produkt von
jedem Zustand mit sich selbst ist eins – und das gilt auch für den L-Null-Zustand.
Und wenn wir uns jetzt unsere zwei Gleichungen ansehen, sehen wir, dass dieser Ausdruck hier gleich dem inneren Produkt der Vektoren ist,
die durch die zwei Gleichungen dargestellt werden. Und insbesondere ist es das innere Produkt zwischen den linken Seiten dieser Gleichungen.
Wir können dieses innere Produkt genauso gut
ausdrücken als das innere Produkt der Vektoren, die durch die rechten
Seiten dieser Gleichungen dargestellt werden,
da die linke Seite
beiden Gleichungen gleich der rechten Seite ist.
Wir erhalten also diesen Ausdruck hier, welcher das innere Produkt
der beiden rechten Seiten der Gleichungen ist, oder äquivalent dazu,
ist es das konjugierte Transponierte des Ersten, multipliziert mit dem Zweiten.
U mal U Dagger ist gleich
der Identitätsmatrix, da U unitär ist und daher wegfällt.
Und wir können ein wenig vereinfachen, um das Produkt
dieser inneren Produkte zu erhalten.
Denk nun daran, dass wir nichts über die Beziehung
zwischen Pi null und Pi eins wissen, sodass wir nicht wissen, was
ihr inneres Produkt ist.
Das ist uns ein Rätsel. Aber egal was es ist, wir multiplizieren es mit dem inneren Produkt von Ket 0 und Ket eins, was null ergibt.
Das Endergebnis ist also, dass
wir den Wert null erhalten, aber das wollten wir zeigen: das innere Produkt zwischen
Psi und Phi ist gleich null.
Die zwei Zustände sind also orthogonal.
Versuch also gar nicht erst,
zwei nicht-orthogonale Quantenzustände
perfekt zu unterscheiden – das ist schlicht unmöglich.
Es gibt eine Umkehrung zu der
Aussage, die wir gerade bewiesen haben: nämlich dass orthogonale Quantenzustände immer perfekt unterschieden werden können,
und das ist nicht allzu schwer zu
sehen, wenn wir eine Tatsache nutzen, die ich früher in der Lektion erwähnt habe.
Wenn Psi und
Phi orthogonale Zustände sind, dann können wir zum Beispiel eine beliebige unitäre Matrix U wählen,
deren erste zwei Spalten
die zwei Zustände sind.
Wir wissen, dass das immer
möglich ist, und es spielt für diese Aufgabe keine Rolle, wie genau diese unitäre Matrix gewählt wird.
Wichtig ist nur, dass dies die ersten zwei Spalten sind.
Wir brauchen keine zusätzlichen Qubits. Wenn wir U einfach auf
die zwei möglichen Zustände anwenden, erhalten wir diese
zwei möglichen Ergebnisse.
Und wenn wir das oberste Qubit messen – das bekanntlich das rechteste Qubit ist –, erhalten wir eine null oder eine eins,
je nachdem, mit welchem Zustand wir begonnen haben.
Alternativ können wir eine
projektive Messung mit Ergebnissen null bis eins betrachten,
die wie hier gezeigt definiert ist.
In diesem Fall hängt die Messung
tatsächlich nur von Psi ab.
Diese Messung unterscheidet Psi
perfekt von jedem Zustand, der orthogonal zu Psi ist.
Wenn wir Psi bezüglich dieser projektiven Messung messen, erhalten wir das Ergebnis
null mit Wahrscheinlichkeit eins, wie diese Gleichungen zeigen.
Und für jeden Zustand Phi,
der orthogonal zu Psi ist, erhalten wir das Ergebnis
eins mit Wahrscheinlichkeit eins.
Ich werde die
Details dieser Berechnungen nicht durchgehen, aber falls du interessiert bist, empfehle ich dir, die
Details selbst durchzuarbeiten.
Damit ist Lektion drei beendet. Wir haben in dieser Lektion viel
Material behandelt, darunter quantum circuits,
innere Produkte und Orthonormalität, Projektionen und projektive Messungen, die Tatsache, dass globale Phasen keine Rolle spielen,
das No-Cloning-Theorem und die Tatsache, dass nicht-orthogonale Zustände nicht perfekt unterschieden werden können, orthogonale Zustände hingegen schon.
Ich hoffe, du bist bald bei
der vierten Lektion dabei, die die letzte Lektion in
der ersten Einheit der Reihe ist.
In der vierten Lektion werden wir über drei
sehr wichtige Beispiele sprechen: Teleportation, Superdense Coding,
und die CHSH-Ungleichung bzw. das CHSH-Spiel, wie es manchmal bezeichnet wird.
Bis dahin, auf Wiedersehen!